no charges will be filed against Brad
Pitt the FBI has closed its
investigation over child abuse
allegations but where does that leave
the fractured jolie-pitt family we have
the latest details on their holiday plan
that's Brad on the red carpet last night
in a trip just hours before the news
broke a big smile on his face blowing
kisses to female fans and taking selfies
the star today definitely has reason to
celebrate but have he and Angelina
called a temporary two-day truce that's
the new headline which claims Angelina
called up Brad after the kids asked them
to be nice to each other for the
holidays it was allegedly 10 year old
Shiloh who wrote her parents an email
begging them to spend Thanksgiving
together but a source tells us these
rumors are quote completely false
Angelina never called that's a quote
total lie they're two people on a
mission they fall in love and is that
love real Brad's press duties for Allied
are officially done the love and war
drama is out today so he could
technically already be back in Los
Angeles to be with the kids but what is
Brad's next move the first thing on Brad
Pitt's agenda must be getting rid of the
monitor visits you don't want to
establish a precedent where the Jolie
camp can use the monitor visits as a way
to supervise him and control him and
sixty five days after Angelina filed for
divorce is this finally the end of the
Brangelina news cycle this has just
begun the average person who files a
no-fault divorce in Los Angeles County
takes about eight months just to get the
paperwork back from the courts when
we're talking about six children
millions and millions of dollars and
their two most famous people in the
world this will take years
[Music]